♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est une jolie maison
de bois comme il en existe
beaucoup à la campagne,
mais celle-ci est particulière.
C'est ici que Joseph Staline
a passé une seule nuit
lors d'une de ses rares
visites au front en 1943.
Autrefois une bibliothèque,
la maison héberge depuis
quatre ans le tout premier musée
entièrement dédié au dictr.r.r.
On y célèbre un héros de guerre
qui a vaincu l'Allemagne nazie.
Mais pas ut t t sur la Grande
Terreur, la famine.
Aucune référence au Goulag
et aux millions de citoyens
exécutés pendant ces 30 ans de
règne sur l'Empire soviétique.
"On le lui a pardonné",
dit Ludimila Sidorova,
une résidente dont les grands-
parents ont pourtant souffert
le martyre dans les campsdedede.
"Mais, ultimement, dit-elle,
c'ââââce à lui et à l'Armée
rouge que nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui."
Cette réhabilitation
de l'héritage de Joseph Staline,
vue de l'extérieur, peut
paraître complètement absurde. e
depuis des années.
Irina Sherbakova est
une des mendndndndndatrices
de la célèbre organisation
Memorial, mise sur pied en 1989
par des dissidents du régime
soviououououour justement faire
la lumière sur les atrocités
du régime stalinien.
ALEXANDRE TCHERKASSOV,
eueueueueur général, Memorial
- Le nombre des victimes
de terreur de Staline,
c'est plus de 20 millions.
- Avec ses bureaux aux quatre
coins du monde, Memorial
a mis trente ans à bâtir
sa base de données, à mettre
un nom et un visage
sur plus de trois millions
et demi de victimes.
Des photos, des lettres,
des uniformes : c'est aussi
la plus grande collection
au monde d'objets du Goulag.
L'ONG est devenue au fil
des ans un emblème de
la mémoire et un pilier
de la société civile russe,
dont les recherches s'étendent
aux violations des droits
de l'homme et aux prisonniers
politiques d'aujourd'hui.
Considéré comme un agent
étranger depuis 2015 par
le Kremlin, comme tant d'autres
voix indépendantes, c'est
cette même organisation,
et tout ce qu'elle
que le gouvernement veut
désormais liquider pour de bon.
- Tout est menacé.
Cet espace, ,,,,,,,
mes collègues...
tout est menacé.
Sans l'aide de Memorial,
Alexander Ovechkin n'aurait
jamais vraiment su ce qui
est arrivé à son grand-père,
un pilote exécuté en secret
en 1938. Nous l'avons joint
à Montréal, d'où il a pu
travailler à distance
avec Memorial pour récupérer
ses effets personnels
des archives du KGB.
Comme tant d'autres, il a
du mal à expliquer l'acharnement
des autorités russes.
- Aujourd'hui, c'est
indésirable. Les listes
des victimes et les héros
de terreur soviétique sontaussis
pour nos autorités.
- Et ça n'a rien de subtil.
Dans le village de Nelidovo,
à 300 km de Moscou, un autre
buste de Staline
d'apparaître dans le décor.
Il est flambant neuf et
gracieuseté
paramilitaire.
Alexander Gordeev en est
trè
"Il y a eu Staline, dit-il,
aujourd'nenenenenenenenene."
Ancien soldat d'élite,
Alexandre enseigne aux jeunes
oioioioioioioioioioindre l'armé.
Ici, Staline inspire le respect
et la stabilité, un sentiment
te aussi dans
les sondages nationaux.
Un Russe sur deux, comme Daniel,
pensent même que le dictateur
sanguinaire mérite un monument
officiel.
"Pour que l'humanité, dit-il,n't
pour nous, les Russes."
(en russe)
- La machine de propagande
actuelle est beaucoup plus forte
que la machine de propagande
de Brejnev ou de Staline.
Le contrôle, aujourd'hui,esesest
répressif, mais c'est
le contrôle discursive.
- C'est falsifier l'histoire
pour mieux contrôler l'avenir.
Et fermer Memorial
s'inscrit, selon lui,
dans cette même optique.
- Si Memorial va être fermé,
c'est le symbole de re
aux temps soviétiques.
♪ ♪